you might have heard about the boring
company's latest project the las vegas
loop which is three taxi stands under a
convention center
connected by a two-way tunnel where we
can drive sports cars real fast
but have you also heard about elon
musk's other project it's called the
dugout loop
and incredibly it's even stupider than
the las vegas loop
it was already bad enough to build
tunnels for tesla cars that operate as
taxis but
wait until you get a load of this [ __ ]
so they wanted to connect the vermont
sunset metro station with dodger stadium
having been built in the 60s the stadium
of course has no good public
transportation connection
because you know cars and so the parking
lot of the stadium is more than
12 times the size of the actual stadium
when i first saw this photo i thought
this was some kind of a
3d render with some like low-res terrain
textures around the stadium
and then i saw that it's just just a
parking lot it's like
holy [ __ ] like this this looks bad and
so let's talk about urban planning
at the place where you should actually
start when you want to fix traffic
issues instead of
going with these flashy [ __ ]
projects in front of you you can see the
great strawsky stadium of prague which
is about two times the size of
dodger stadium and next to it there are
three other stadiums actually
a two mid-sized and one smaller now
strawski is an absolute [ __ ] monster
it can accommodate a quarter of a
million people
of which 56 thousand seated which also
happens to be the total capacity of
dodger stadium
and next to it is the avgenerositsko
stadium with a capacity of 19 000 people
so these are the available parking areas
around the stadiums
marked with red now having just seen
that disaster show around the dodger
stadium you might ask
how the [ __ ] is this possible and the
answer is of course good public
transportation
now the metro lines don't actually stop
at the stadium as you can see the green
and the yellow metros
actually give a wide berth to the
stadium itself so how do people get to
the matches
by buses and trams that all stop next to
or near the stadiums
and there's also a cable car actually
and i'm telling you all this to show you
that even the largest stadium in the
world
plus three other stadiums around it
could be served by
adjacent tram and bus lines you know
it's not like there's a metro line
stopping underneath the stadium or
something
instead what you do is get off at the
tram station and walk over to the
stadium
or you know just take a bus so with this
in mind let's return to dodger stadium
the boring company wanted to start
digging from the stadium's parking lot
to the vermont sunset station
underneath the road neatly following its
route because of a public right-of-way
otherwise they would need to acquire
costly easements if they would be
tunneling under private property
so this is a picture of the western
terminus of the dugout loop
now this is the entire station this is
not part of it
this is the whole thing now that being
said can you see what the problem is
i'm going to leave you a few seconds
have you noticed
the whole system has one tunnel a
single one-way tunnel connecting the
metro line and the stadium parking lot
so how is this system supposed to
operate let's take a look
they plan on running these autonomous
electric pods in them
capable of transporting 16 people each
now for comparison that is
almost 20 of a regular bus and around 10
percent of an articulated bus
so right off the bat we got terrible
efficiency and this is called economy of
scale
it's much more economical and
environmentally friendly
to have one big motor transport a lot of
people at the same time
than to have lots of smaller motors
transporting smaller quantities of
people
so here the logical solution would be to
increase the pots capacity
but that that that can't be done that's
that's impossible uh you see
these these are these are pods pods
not a minibus so yeah this is a problem
you notice with a lot of these uh
futuristic [ __ ] projects it's not
buses or trains
for the sake of not being buses or
trains they're pods
but i'm just gonna call the dugout loop
pods minibuses because
that's what they are and you might think
if these vehicles have like a fixed
route
basically a single line between point a
and point b they would be running on
rails
because you know that's the most
efficient way of running fixed route
things from point a to point b
with minimal friction but nope the
tunnel will be paved and the minibuses
will have rubber wheels
you know i wonder why they just don't
sink some rails into the asphalt like
tram tracks for example and then have
these vehicles have two modes which is a
technology we do have and use
these are road vehicles that can change
between rubber wheels and steel wheels
so if the boring company didn't want to
mess with stuff that is beyond its
expertise like
switches for example they could just
build a long straight tunnel with some
tram tracks sunk into the asphalt and at
the beginning and the end the vehicles
just quickly switch between their wheels
but first off that would look too much
like a train which we can't have of
course
and second inconvenient questions might
arise such as
okay why don't we run like a tram in it
instead or a
light metro or something yeah that
sounds good so then why are we bothering
with these minibuses again
wait what no no no shut up the emperor's
clothes are beautiful it's just the
stupid people can't see them
so the trip time between the metro stop
and the stadium parking lot will be just
under 4 minutes according to the website
and this will be achieved by these
minibuses traveling at up to 150 miles
per hour which is 240 kilometers per
hour
on this stretch of 3.6 miles or 5.8
kilometers
and the problem is this doesn't seem to
be possible
because the curves are just too god damn
narrow and if you look at this curve in
normal illinois
thanks for the idea do not eat this
thing was designed for traffic going 100
miles per hour
which is only two-thirds of what the
boring company wants to do with the
dugout loop
so here it is overlaid on the dugout
loop's route so as you can see the
dugout loops proposed route would not
work with even 100 miles per hour much
less with 150
but putting aside all of that there's a
second problem namely tire wear
if you don't want too much tire wear you
have to avoid two things
high speeds and frequent acceleration
and deceleration which is incidentally
what these minibuses would do
you know i'm glad that the boring
company is all about zero emissions
but this noble goal is kind of
overshadowed if you're producing tons of
rubber waste every month
man if only there was a solution but
believe it or not what you've heard so
far
is not the stupidest part of this
project so let's move on to how the
boring company actually plans to operate
this thing
oh boy so as i said before the metro
stop and the parking lot of the stadium
will be connected by
a single tunnel and to use it you need
to buy a ticket
at the ticket office or in an app get to
the station at the specified time
get transported to the stadium watch the
match and then go back down to the
dugout loop which will then take you
back to the metro stop
as they write on their website dugout
loop operation during games and special
events will be event specific
generally transportation from the
western terminus to dodger stadium
will begin prior to event start times
transport from dodger stadium to the
western terminus will generally commence
sometime following the start of the
event
which is you know it's a system where
what so basically elon musk invented a
shitty route taxi
and he put a [ __ ] tunnel over it for
some reason so uh
okay so since this is an extremely time
specific service
meaning it only runs in very very
specific times
why don't we just ditch the tunnel idea
yeah so let's have these pods run on the
surface
make them bigger and so voila let's call
it the dodger stadium express
now some of you might be saying hang on
a second the whole point of the dugout
loop is that it's a fast dedicated lane
system
to which i say let's take one of the
five lanes of the road leading to the
stadium
and convert one or two into a bus lane
for the time of the event
and if you want to make it really fast
we can employ this technology that every
western european city already employs
called automatic greenway for buses
right
so let's move on to capacity the boring
company website says
initially dugout loop will be limited to
approximately 1400 people approximately
2.5 percent of stadium capacity
per event based on city and community
feedback it could be possible to
increase ridership per game to 2800 per
game
or event 5 of stadium capacity between
games and events dugout loop would
transport a quarter or million people
per year wait between games so they
actually do want to use this as like
normal public transportation outside of
events
okay so 250 000 people per year this
might sound a lot actually
but as a european i have to say like
this this number is nothing
like like this is nothing this is [ __ ]
you don't have anything
this is not public transportation and to
illustrate this point let's look at the
closest thing i know to the dugout loop
in europe it sounds funny but it's
actually kind of similar
and it's the budapest m1 metro line or a
milani without divashud built during the
late 19th century and thus was the first
electrified metro service on the
continent
it was a small electric underground
environmentally friendly
express service going just underneath
the andrashi avenue from the city center
all the way to the
giant park that's behind hiro square so
what they did was they actually
dug out the road built the tunnels and
then filled it back up it took two years
to complete and it's operational to this
day
originally they ran these small cements
carriages on it which i guess were the
pods of the era
and apparently one of the original cars
is today in the seashore trolley museum
in kennebunkport main
which you know that's cool these metro
cars were later replaced by trains of
hungarian production
which were higher in capacity but the
system itself is still
tiny this is by no means a regular metro
service
it's a little baby line and yet this
thing
transports 80 000 passengers on each
workday
and if we assume that the number of
passengers is only half on weekends
then this tiny toy metro transports 25
million
120 000 passengers each year and so this
is what the passenger numbers look like
when i put them on a graph
compared to the toy metro the dugout
loop is barely a statistical error and
if we compare this to a normal metro
line like the m3
and using the same formula we get this
graph i'm showing you this just for the
sake of perspective
the dugout loop is is nothing it does
nothing it serves no one
it doesn't even exist when compared to
like normal well-designed systems
and you might be saying hey it's a bit
unfair to compare the duck outlook to
the m3 metro
and yes it is so i just compare it to
the m1 which is actually shorter than
the dugout loop
and they could actually finish it in two
years using 19th century technology
meanwhile the boring company said they
would do the dugout loop in 14 months
using elon's [ __ ] magic space age
technology
hey but they did say likely much less in
parentheses there so it's okay
you know construction projects
historically finish on time and never
get delayed
and mind you it's 14 months for a single
tunnel
whereas with the m1 metro they had to
dig a tunnel twice as wide
and don't forget that they had to build
a bunch of stations as well
in contrast the las vegas loop which is
unfortunately happening
took 16 months to complete while being
less than a fourth of the length of the
proposed dugout loop
at 0.8 miles or 1.3 kilometers
so basically the dugout loop was a
complete [ __ ]
failure on all levels literally i cannot
think of a single
aspect which the dugout loop got right
its layout is nonsensical
it has no capacity is not interoperable
with any other systems
it has horribly inefficient energy use
and worst of all
had this thing been built it would have
pushed out actually useful public
transportation investment in the area
so what would be an actual good solution
here what could the area do instead of
the dugout loop
well for example build a tram take two
lanes from sunset boulevard and turn
them into dedicated tram tracks
lord knows there is enough space for
that and this will actually not cause
traffic jams because induced demand
works the other way around as well
you could put a tram stop next to the
stadium and perhaps turn part of the
parking lot into
actual useful public space such as a
city park or something
in general though traffic problems will
not go away by just throwing capacity at
it which is what the boring company does
basically oh
your highway is congested well let's
just build some more lanes but
underground
because increasing capacity worked out
so well in the past but here's the thing
even if they would solve all the traffic
problems even if they would build enough
tunnels
so that there will be no more traffic
jams at all like anywhere just zero
that would still be a very very bad
thing because if you provide everyone
with road capacity so that they can
drive
then everyone will drive driving itself
is actually very cost and time efficient
on
short and middle distances and also it's
much more comfortable than public
transit
however the bad part is everything else
cars are horribly spacing inefficient
they make us fatter they cost a lot of
money to buy maintain and operate
they kill a lot of people and producing
them is actually very environmentally
unfriendly especially with the batteries
and all that
and even if some of these problems could
be alleviated by
gigantic underground tunnel systems and
parking lot complexes
switching over society to cars would
produce a lot of socioeconomic and
environmental fallout for places that
don't have these things
in prague they built this huge system of
underground highways to alleviate the
traffic
problems and guess what it didn't solve
anything in fact it only made the
problems worse
8 out of 10 people from around the city
commute into the city by car
and the result is clogged up streets and
constant traffic jams
in the places where there aren't any
highway tunnels in the end we should
focus on building urban areas where
having a core is not a necessity or even
disincentivized if you want to start
combating climate change effectively we
should stop dragging two tons of metal
and plastic with us wherever we go
and the planning of neighborhoods should
enable this choice you know like new
urbanism walkable city 10-minute
neighborhood all these things
it's a complex and difficult solution to
a complex and difficult problem
and i don't think it's a good idea to
look to rich out-of-touch car maker
billionaires
to just solve climate change with a
revolutionary idea or two or in the case
of elon musk
flashy cgi remakes of century-old ideas
because if an idea sounds too good to be
true then it
probably is and if you're a fan of elon
musk who happened to chance upon this
video
please understand that this video is not
meant to be against you
my goal is to help you look beyond the
flashy cgi and the big promises
and just think about what you hear about
what you see about what people promise
you
you might disagree with some of what i
said maybe most of it perhaps even all
of it
but it's okay because it is my hope that
i at least got you to think about it
think about what it means to be
environmentally friendly what public
transportation should be
etc still if you feel the urge to hurl
some insults my way in the comment
section
feel free i guarantee to completely
ignore all of it so thank you for
watching like subscribe all that and
i'll see you next time